the Joe Rogan experience yeah I mean
you've worked for a bunch of different
companies before you've done things it's
like it can be great you can work with a
bunch of cheerful people or absolutely a
disaster you got some time suck in the
middle of the [ __ ] mix and they they
just the demand too much attention
there's too much conflict and nonsense
and yeah interpersonal drama and
sometimes people start [ __ ] oh yeah
people that work together start [ __ ]
and then you have to hear the opinions
of both of them while you pretend you
don't know that they're [ __ ] that
this is weighing heavily on the way
they're communicating with everybody
else like oh yeah that's supporting each
other and you're supposed to support
them too now their relationship has
become center stage in your office
that's like one of the reasons why
people don't want office romances not
even just because women don't want to be
harassed by men that are trying to [ __ ]
them all the time so just say no one can
do it but also because once it of
relationship does happen one of two
things yeah either it'll everyone's
roped yeah either it'll go great and
everyone's gonna be a part of it so your
relationship becomes a part of the whole
ecosystem of the office mm-hmm or it'll
go terrible and people have to pick
sides and or one of you has to leave
yeah like so or bad dude you you if you
amongst the most miraculous people you
have a amicable split and you become
really good friends afterwards you still
work together with no problems even like
each other spouses
Yeah right it is possible it's possible
it's happened I'm sure it's happened
yes but much much more rare if I was
running a company
I'd be like listen you guys can't bang
each other yes I know it sounds gross I
know you hear all day buts problem is
like what if you met the girl of your
dreams on a job that was your dream job
they're like [ __ ] what do you do you
have to make this like a [ __ ]
Jennifer Lopez movie right yeah totally
like like - yeah I'll - successful I
don't give a [ __ ] about this job
Jennifer I want to be with you don't
play the music it's like no you don't
have to quit I'll quit you know [ __ ]
this I but I've got a grab no you can't
and then they decide to start their own
firm yeah if it was a real chick movie
the girl would have like the smaller
paycheck - and the guy would lose the
bigger paycheck and he would he would
come she would come home
from work and he would be wearing
[ __ ] like like an apron and he would
be mopping yes that would be great
well I guess I guess I should get used
to it like that's my life now
like the perfect job I gave up my
perfect job for the perfect woman yeah
yeah yeah that would suck
if you had the dream job but you met a
girl there who she was single and she
was into you and you're both into each
other and you like goddamnit what do you
do you start banging and don't tell
anyway that's what you do right prom
probably or if you're like super pro and
super committed you just figure out a
way not to and just kind of maybe come
up with an agreement or something I
don't know plot your exit yes you'll
apply your eggs always know your exits
while you're lying about banging each
other yes
yeah you got a lie gonna lie and say
yeah yeah we're going the movies tonight
my friend Melissa
anyway Todd's house for some dick that
sucks
such a terrible way to live guys don't
do it yeah worth it well the most
terrible probably live in the closet
that's probably the most terrible that's
the most it's a super unnecessary one I
think yeah well no in some case it's not
at all yeah well it's also like it's
symbolic you know we all have things in
the innit closet I mean that's like
that's like a pretty big level that's
noticeable but many many people but in a
way it is a metaphor for like there are
a lot of things that we don't allow
ourselves to sure like let people know
about and especially in the corporate
world right you're you're forced to
present a air quotes professional image
and this enhances your ability to earn
living it enhances your ability to be
successful inside that corporate
structure so you you literally have to
play a role all the time which is why if
you talk to women who are dominatrix is
one of the things that they say is the
the guys who really like to get kicked
in the balls and [ __ ] on are the guys
who run businesses the guys are like
yeah they need to feel it yeah that's
feel alive kicking the balls they need
someone pissing in their mouth they need
something to get smacked they want to
get crazy because they're so buttoned
down all day long that could barely take
it
I'm so lucky Reggie you're so lucky an
artist so like son of a [ __ ] I love it
so I'm doing a cubicle right now mad at
you [ __ ] him no man you guys can live
your dreams I mean yeah I mean it's it's
rats and people about credit card loans
yeah I know well you know we could be do
more of us could be more creative but
we're really designing there's a society
to support that yeah we you and I can't
fix the streets and fix it straight no
but we can inspire people to fix the
streets it yeah of course I mean you
know sometimes it just takes a little
kick in the and the yarbles
[Applause]